hi there Steve Kaufman here today I want
to talk about language learning and a
very famous successful book self-help
book by Stephen Covey called the seven
Habits of Highly Effective People I read
this and I'll tell you why I read it is
because I found an audio book of this
sim Nabokov Visakha affective Nick Luce
when I was in Riga so I bought the book
and I bought the I'll be working listen
to it and so and so on it has
application for language learning and
basically the seven habits that Covey
talks about our one and he kind of it's
too complicated first thing is to become
independent he says well this is
extremely important for language
learning and it consists of first of all
one being proactive you have to take
charge of your language journey I've
discussed this before to start with the
end goal in mind so if you're starting
to learn a language make sure you know
exactly what you want to achieve you
want to learn it to this degree of
fluency in fact visualize yourself
reaching that goal in my opinion three
he talks about do first things first and
to me that means like if you're going to
study a language and if you intend to
achieve this end goal that you have in
mind do it every day
and make sure you do it every day and as
I've talked about have your you know mp3
player with you and have your text with
you and if whatever and whenever you
have an opportunity do it so that gets
you independent the second thing he
talks about is becoming you know
interdependent with other people now
he's talking about management working
with people of course we're talking
about language learning so to the extent
that were communicating with other
people of course being interdependent is
important so to get to this
interdependence the fourth thing he says
was to think in terms of win-win all
right if you're negotiating with someone
then of course win-win it's important
where I see this applies to language
learning is no matter what you do
considered a win you're struggling with
a text you really didn't understand it
well it was somehow frustrating you
don't think your May
any progress but you spent half an hour
an hour listening reading whatever to
whatever extent you understood it it's a
win because you expose yourself to the
language it's a win so everything's a
win when you're studying a language then
the fifth thing he talks about is and
try to understand then worry about being
understood so if you're a manager of
course you want to first understand your
people before you even expect them to
understand what you want from them to me
this is extremely important in the
language learning I stress this all the
time it's more important to understand
than speak if you can become if you can
have that confidence that you understand
what you hear you understand what you
read you understand the language you
have the vocabulary the speaking will
come it'll come from speaking but if you
don't understand it's very difficult to
have meaningful communication the sixth
thing was synergy and I think synergy
also applies to language learning
because all of our activities all of the
different learning activities reading
listening speaking writing they are all
synergistic because everything we do
increases our ability to notice so
there's obvious synergy in all of our
learning activities so we're doing this
number six of Stephen Covey and the
seventh thing he talks about is what he
calls sharpening the saw now there is
constantly developing your skills and I
think building up your passive
vocabulary building up your familiarity
with the language all of this is making
you potentially a better speaker of the
language so you are in fact sharpening
the saw now in subsequent videos I'll
get into more detail on some of these
seven Habits of Highly Effective People
but you can google for it and I think
look at how this applies to language
learning and I look forward to your
comments thank you for listening